amidst fireworks bright lights and a
foreboding warning One Moment In the new
trailer for season three of the
Mandalorian has fans buzzing with
excitement there's a new trailer for the
third season of the Mandalorian and that
means Star Wars fans everywhere are
coming together to find every small
detail it teases this includes the
return of characters like Captain Carson
Teva Dr Pershing Pali Moto grief karga
and more we also saw an allusion to the
past of the Mandalorian in the form of a
statue of ig-11 commemorating his
sacrifice there's also the return of the
iconic B1 droids which are often the
butt of jokes in series such as Star
Wars the Clone Wars and Star Wars the
bad batch huh what's happened
what's happening I don't know did we win
however there's one detail in particular
that fans on Reddit found particularly
interesting and believe might hint at
what might be happening in the
mandalorian's third season about one
minute into the trailer we see a
bustling City with tall skyscrapers and
flying ships everywhere although the
Galaxy likely holds more than one city
with that description the most iconic
one in Star Wars is almost definitely
Coruscant which is a planet entirely
covered by a giant City on Reddit one
user simply exclaimed Coruscant with
another adding host episode 6 Coruscant
this is notable because at least in the
Star Wars shows and films we have never
seen the city Planet chronologically
after Star Wars Return of the Jedi this
means that we would get to see
coruscantas we've never seen it before
potentially gaining news on what has
happened there since the dismantling of
the Empire and the death of Emperor
Palpatine another redditor wrote I hope
we get it post rise of Skywalker 2 since
so many people still think it was
destroyed in the force awakens I hate
that they made the surface of hosnian
prime so similar to Coruscant by the
massive skyscrapers this is referring to
was seen in the force awakens in which
the first order destroys the similar
looking City planets which led many to
believe Coruscant was no more as has
been shown recently in the 2022 series
Andor coruscantes is where most of the
franchise's politics take place as it is
the home of whatever government tends to
rule the galaxy at the time whether it
be good or evil since amandalorian takes
place after the Galactic Empire but
before the rise of the first order this
may be one of the few times we get to
see the planet in relative peace though
we know that this piece will be
short-lived of course fans on Reddit are
excited by this possibility a user wrote
I'm really hoping the return of
Coruscant delivers on some much needed
new Republic development
responding to this comment another
redditor said we could only hope gonna
be weird with it just being a planet
though considering the new Republic's
stupid decision of not making it the
galactic Capital this is because the new
Republic decided to make their home
planet hosnian Prime which doesn't seem
to appear in any of the trailers for The
Mandalorian season 3 so far although
many people believe the planets is
Coruscant and are excited by the
prospect others aren't as convinced one
Reddit user believes the planet might
actually be hosnian prime which also
features lots of skyscrapers and being
the capital of the new Republic might
make more sense to feature they're
indeed delving into that government's
politics they write could technically be
hosnian prime which also has pretty
Urban Landscapes another redditor isn't
convinced the planet is either of those
two however writing I don't think that's
Coruscant I think it's chandrilla they
might be right since a planet was
referenced in Andor with his new
relevance to chandrilla it might be time
to finally get a closer look at the
planet especially since it served as the
first capital of the new Republic before
it was ultimately moved to hosnian Prime
the Mandalorian season 3 premieres on on
Disney Plus on March 1st
[Music]